eux qui font la politique c'est vous
quels pièges du mal tu m'as dumas entend
pas mon chéri il faut que tu apprennes à
migros valais donné à minima parce qu'il
est bien chaud on aime bien quand il
parle du show et je suis breton vendéen
qui sait qu'il faut condamner ces les
présidents des associations qui font des
militants et les militants qu'est-ce
qu'ils font monsieur vous savez ce
qu'ils font les militants ils nous
harcèlent
ils disent qu'ils vont brûler nos
caravanes et dire brûler nos cirques
vous le savez c'est écrit jeudi semblant
d'accord n'est pas sans risque dit c'est
qu'on en est rendu là parce que s'il y
aurait pas les débilités comment les
dirigeants
il y aurait pas les militants derrière
et de défendre une cause je suis
d'accord je suis alors j'ai vous plaît
avant de respecter les gens quelle
droite à voir quels sont les choix faits
je la mange bien j'ai pas content
[Applaudissements]
jeudi respecterez de chaque année entre
3 à l'identique avez vous du mal le
message c'est que je te commande une
côte de boeuf la fois alors on va parler
du cirque s'il vous plaît pas cela c'est
vrai qu'un de mes spectacles
j'entends mines d'or et moi quand je
vois tous ces gens là tous et tous ces
jeunes hommes qui sont extrêmement sais
rien
il faudra pas là restent et qui sont
passionnés te déshabille pas quand même
du mal c'est parti ça mais on va tenez
pas compte de boeuf t'inquiète pas il a
le pitch heures on va t'amener à un bon
kilo est inquiète femmes
t'inquiète pas mon chéri je vais te
donner un truc tu veux d'amélie des
petits écoliers des conneries à al
ajilat ses bras il veut du mal à me
mellul mais vu la formule à vis de 80 je
suis généreux regardez bien il demain 20
heures demain à 21 heures
ouais les militants ont mis qu' il
allait enlever toutes mes affiches dans
la ville où je me suis blessé
voilà donc on n'a plus le droit de faire
notre métier on est un mets tes capillon
sur rue parce que le cirque ça passe pas
inaperçu dès qu'on arrive dans une ville
dont le seuil serait donc y aller les
journaux les radios tout ça ça vient de
cirque et là les criminels sont là il
faut aller les tuer et l'harcèlement je
suis désolé harcèlement six ou sept
manifestations depuis le début de
l'année c'est pas du harcèlement que ça
devant des entreprises égard le droit
d'exploiter leur métier vous trouvez que
c'est pas du harcèlement de venir devant
la porte de drapeaux du marseillais dans
des mégaphones et faire peur aux enfants
qui viennent au cirque et en disant aux
gens vous cautionnez la maltraitance
animale parce qu'ils m'ont retiré mais
ça c'est pas le respect de l'humain
on est en france vers la liberté du
roseland et oui à la liberté du droit de
l'homme dans notre pays
calme toi tu m'as que tu vas pas
sur 100 euros bas dès bons mais l'argent
serve micro micro électro mécaniques
l'allemande un chapiteau de 5000 places
pelouse oraux y les exemples sont ici et
fragrant 5000 places depuis des années
toujours des recettes complète l'année
passée il a écouté hidalgo il a fait
cirque sans animaux devant dernier
histoire assez ville à monter un
chapiteau de 1500 places avait du mal à
avoir 500 personnes à ses spectacles un
meilleur avenir pour le dos camille
lacourt en moins alors si les cirques
sans animaux ferait le plein arlette
gruss cache derrière la bruce allen
mille personnes et 1 130 personnes à
nancy c'est vrai des chiffres
s'il te plaît dumas on voit ce que tu a
réveillé tout le voisinage
je tiens le tir parce que mon intérêt la
mairie de paris pendant des mois la
mairie de paris a organisé des réunions
entre votre pendant deux ans pendant
deux ans avec les circassiens et là il
leur propose de l'argent pour arrêter
ses tirs de la solution un drop mais
l'europe ou pas les chameaux des cires
pendant et non à 150 euros la tonne donc
il faut forer vont réfléchir non
délimitées d'euros sur cinq ans et demi
le vertige de lire c'est quoi ces mêmes
valeurs décotées avant que chaque vous
avez mon papa c'est un autre appartement
qui crèvent de faim avant l'année rf
autres il a dix mille euros c'est quoi
la mairie de paris vous ai travaillé
deux ans au gaz cirque français a été
invité à ces débats seulement qui est
l'un des rares net et bouclions qui sont
jamais sans ma dernière nous ayons
jamais les derniers que des animaux à
paris il est chez lui fait ce qu'il veut
même chose vous êtes en train de
recenser l'opinion publique pourquoi
pour des élections c'est simplement des
électeurs vous voulez c'est tout dumas
c'est la dictature du mas et tous pour
toi
non non ça y est là si on peut parler de
dialogue des frères ont aimé alors
qu'elle applique karine et 00h29 à
suresnes longchamp s'est produit sur la
question du mas je dire on n'est pas sur
un dialogue républicain où on peut
trouver un consensus au milieu comme
monsieur disait le problème qui a su
conserver ou on n'est pas contre à faire
une amélioration sauf que l'autre côté
on veut l'interdiction paie donc ya pas
donc vous l'avez à faire un pas vous non
on veut bien faire même deux côtés ne
veulent pas ils demandent à l'état
on veut à l'interdire quoi votre prime
pas sur toi c'est quoi bon c'est très
bien car on sait d'où elle a fait des
propositions au gouvernement
non je fais par une question je prends
mes 12 lyon j'enlève les cages et lâche
dans la rue bon ils vont faire quoi à
votre avis ils vont faire croire bon bah
ils vont manger non faire du cirque 100
à 200 animaux ce que c'est possible
c'est impossible à temps est à
souleymane ton pote hissbach voisine ait
rien qui statuent vos toiles bouffer tu
as mal au dos tu veux que j'appelle un
qui défraie la corde requip artois comm
ca vas y fais toi plaisir
[Applaudissements]